let's talk about uh the end of the world
I guess yeah we have this story from
Newsweek Germany says quiet part out
loud about Ukraine war
you know if you Google search Germany
declares war on Russia this is the story
you get and uh the reason why is
Germany's foreign minister said we are
at War
so it's not a formal declaration of war
she's literally
you know I would say in the colloquial
sense she is declaring that they are at
war with Russia yeah this basically
means NATO basically means us yeah it
loves Mike Michael Tracy tweeted Jeremy
declares war on Russia right posting
this video of her saying it and then he
got fact checked on Twitter saying there
has been no formal declaration of war
and he was like no one said there was
I'm saying that she is declaring war on
Russia so we have we also have this
story which goes along with it
Russia says it will consider the
deployment of German Leopard two tanks
as the use of nuclear dirty bomb if they
use shells containing uranium core all
right there we go so Russia is going to
come out and say you started the nuclear
war first yeah all of this is escalation
everything that we do to help Ukraine is
escalation anything anyone in the west
and all of it to Russia looks is Russia
is taking it for exactly what it is
which is every Western NATO country
trying to help Ukraine defeat Russia
there is not a situation where Russia
gets beaten back
and and and leaves uh leaves crime here
and stuff like that and that's what a
lot of people are talking about I don't
um I can't imagine why anyone believes
that that would happen well you're
you're running yeah right so uh 2024
people have the chance to vote for you
you will be in what's your view on how
we handle a situation like this cut off
Ukraine no involvement what do you think
send weapons we need to move towards
de-escalation the little bit of Leverage
that we have right now is that we're
we're bankrolling all this escalation I
mean the German the Germans right now
are getting all of the attention but a
couple months ago we had Dick Durbin on
the floor of the of the Congress saying
that we're at war with Russia Biden has
said you can't remain in power he's used
regime change rhetoric the same stuff we
said about Saddam and Gaddafi so we've
continued to drive the Train on
escalation I would like to use the
leverage that we have to get both sides
to the negotiating table we also threw a
huge uh sanctions package against the
Russians so I think we're in a position
right now and our time window for this I
think is unfortunate fortunately very
short where we could say look Ukraine if
you guys want any more aid for anything
you have to be actively involved in
negotiations with the Russians working
towards the ceasefire and then offer
Putin sanctions relief and also make a
guarantee to him that we're not going to
expand NATO like NATO should not be on
the border of Russia that was the
containment doctrine that got us through
the Cold War without any kind of nuclear
escalation like this but right now the
only elected officials I hear talking
about de-escalation it's a handful of
Republicans in the house and the Senate
and then the only world leader is Donald
Trump that's saying that hey
negotiations are what we need to be
doing it's crazy
the Doomsday Clock gets moved 90 seconds
to midnight because of the Ukraine war
not that I think a Doomsday Clock means
anything other than a handful of
scientists are like we're going to blow
ourselves up I just happen to agree with
their opinion that this is a dangerous
and incorrect direction to go but look
Kevin McCarthy is wearing the Ukraine
flag stuff it's the only thing I see in
this is they're not going to back down
there we are it's a bad Grace headed
right for the edge of a cliff yeah it is
100 and then the crazy thing to me is
that no one's no one in our leadership
has had the respect for the American
people to explain to them this is why
you hear a bunch of rhetoric you hear
that you're either with us or you're a
Putin sympathizer I get called that
occasionally you know but they don't say
hey guys
um we're actually going to have your
your elected representatives as per the
U.S Constitution go and argue the case
they can come back to the district and
say hey this is this is why we think
this is important and if things go wrong
we could end up in a war in Eastern
Europe are you guys good with that you
guys you guys want to sign on to that
but they don't do that I kind of feel
like uh these people in government
should should play some poker because
I've been I've been playing a bunch of
poker online I played it at the casino
for the first time and uh you learn the
lesson about folding for those that play
poker I'm not like good or like I'm not
comprehend to be good or anything but
like the first time I started playing
I'm like I got no idea what's going on
and then I'm like yeah I'll bet I'm like
oh that was dumb I just lost all my
money and eventually you learn like I
made a few bets I thought my hand was
good but now I think he's probably
better he's pushing hard I'm going to
cut my losses I've lost on this I've
lost money on this I'm losing this fight
but the ultimate winning position in the
end is going to be to accept that and
Retreat and it feels like none of these
people can accept that that you're both
raising the stakes against each other
right and in the end there's no winner
nobody's taken home any prize no it's
going to be a heap of Ash and nuclear
waste yeah and the best bet is to be
like we lost 100 billion dollars
you're going to lose the Don bass region
yeah or you're going to lose the planet
yeah I mean or just say hey look this I
mean the the conflict between the the
border of Russia and Ukraine has been
going along on longer than America has
been a country and so for us just to say
get to the negotiating table what you
guys work out on your own border that is
up to you we're not going to further
escalate this by pushing NATO up but
what we want is we want the Bloodshed
here to stop because right now who's
dying it's ukrainians are dying they're
getting thrown into the meat grinder the
Russians don't care about casualties
like for all the the military analysts
out there who are like oh the the
Russians you know they can't sustain
this they they haven't lost in
comparison to other times Russia's
fought Wars they haven't even come close
to what they're willing to lose and
Russia's just look it's it's a much
bigger country than Ukraine there's
gonna have to be some form of realism
injected into this Russia is the zap
Branigan of countries
sending wave after wave of their own men
to die until they finally win this is
this is what they were famous for with
the uh I correct me if I'm wrong because
I'm not like a story or thing but I was
reading about in World War II yeah
Russia opted for mass production of low
quality weapons and tanks but lots of
them yeah so while the West is like
let's make the best tank in the world
and then when it blows up you're like
okay it took a long time Russia was like
get a bunch of metal boxes and just keep
sending them out and don't stop yeah
that's what they're doing with their
artillery right now I mean there's a lot
of talk about it we got to send them
javelins we're going to send them tanks
we're going to send them high Mars and
the Russians are just like we're gonna
pulverize these towns and it's horrible
they shouldn't be doing this but they're
going to pulverize the towns World War
One World two Style with artillery with
missile systems and then they're gonna
have their mercenaries come in who are
mostly released prisoners come in yeah
and if a couple thousand of them die
they don't care most people don't
realize that artillery wins Wars like
especially in Europe like artillery has
killed more human beings in war than any
other means because artillery is the
king of battle like if they put
artillery on the on the on the border
they can level like I don't know how far
artillery goes 20 30 40 miles yeah it's
also um it's the risk assessment how
much are you willing to lose and I think
it's fair to say Russia is willing to
lose a lot more than we are absolutely
oh yeah and that puts us in a very weak
position when it comes to leverage and
when it comes to getting getting called
that should be obvious sorry this fight
is just so different than
compared to because Ukraine
say that like we in the beginning of
this there was a call between Vladimir
Putin and Biden and Vladimir Putin just
asked like will you promise that Ukraine
won't join NATO and Biden was like I
can't do that like why are you getting
involved in this yeah Regional debate
like fight which obviously it's violence
terrible but it is so much more
complicated I mean zielinski I just
wrote about this today but zielinski in
December was like we should kick out one
of the churches because uh Eastern
Orthodoxy is the dominant religion in
Ukraine and there are two sacks and they
split uh in 2020 I believe and now
zelinsky's like if they if the church
reports to Moscow which it does I don't
want them operating here I mean it is
such a divisive region already we have
nothing to compare it to and I don't
understand like why our leaders would
think this is something that we should
just just insert ourselves into and if
we get it wrong the consequences are
nuclear war I mean we just got out of 20
years of disastrous war in the Middle
East but this isn't going to be like the
wars in the Middle East where we can be
like you know what the American people
don't care anymore you guys just want to
leave Afghanistan and we just we fly I
mean it was a tragedy we lost 13 we
didn't need to lose we don't really fly
out faster you know and the same thing
we left our accurate to go back then we
left again and we can kind of absorb all
that because we're a strong Nation it
was tragic we shouldn't have done it but
this is completely different and I think
we have a bunch of people who are
thinking like oh a fight in Ukraine
that's going to be sort of like we just
did in the global war on terror you know
worst case scenario like we just leave
who cares like that's that's not the way
this is gonna play out no not at all
yeah Russia's got a bunch of nuclear
weapons right they have more than the
U.S and they're right and they're saying
that the use of these uh uranium core
shells will be using nuclear dirty bombs
yeah so Russia could come out and just
claim they did the news reporting is
there and they're going to say hey
they're using nuclear weapons and then
Russia is going to make an announcement
like we have no choice but to respond in
kind this is the fault of the West for
the escalation to the use of nuclear
weapons yeah but I also kind of Wonder
like how much do appearances matter
you're right so one of the reasons these
the US and Russia are trying to avoid
dramatic escalation like nuclear weapons
is because we still have to trade with
our other countries and if the U.S went
nuts and said started firing nukes we
might get isolated we people are going
to get mad at us so obviously that
factors in but if Russia is looking at
the end of their Nation or even Putin at
the end of his power yeah he's going to
be like I don't care what anyone thinks
right it's about what you're going to
lose at some point you're like if we do
nothing we're done yeah so even if we
can find a way to navigate this even if
these of these weapons will piss off our
allies it's either piss off our allies
or cease to exist yeah yeah they're
going to pick the obvious one yeah
anyway through the kitchen sink at them
right away the the sanctions package
where we just completely and totally cut
them off in the west that took away our
ability to make that more gradual so now
I think we need to start giving him an
exit ramp from that so he's not beholden
by to China right but then I mean the
whole thing is just so much more
escalation we're just heading towards
this point where we're not gonna be able
to walk it back and plus there's so many
experts right now who are trying to
predict like what's going to happen next
here and there right now in the fog of
battle no one can predict what's going
to happen next and there's a lot of
folks that are giving the American
people some sort of false hope that like
we're completely and totally in control
we're gonna we're gonna give the
ukrainians these tanks and we know
exactly what the what the repercussions
are going to be thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time